And then it's possible to start to
feel frustrated because I continue
not understanding this stuff.
Hi, Steve Kaufmann here, and today I want
to talk about focus in language learning.
All right?
And the reason I'm doing that is because,
recently I've had, sort of, problems...
oh, by the way, if you enjoy
my videos, please click on
the bell for notifications.
You know, please subscribe and
if you follow me on a podcast
service, please leave a comment.
I do appreciate it.
So focus.
So I was having trouble with my camera.
All of a sudden it was all out of focus.
So the background was outta focus and
even where I was speaking was kind of out
of focus and I couldn't get it to work.
And no matter what I did, I
couldn't get the focus sharp
the way it's supposed to be.
Now, fortunately, my son was over
and he grabbed the camera and he
identified by deduction that, you know,
all of the stuff that I was trying
to change, you know, auto focus this
and that, I'd never touched before.
So, maybe Dad, it's not so smart to think
that that's gonna solve the problem.
It's something else.
And sure enough, there was a
setting that, you know, that you
kind of, either you were in VA
for, I guess video or something.
That's where I was.
That's not where I was supposed to be.
I was supposed to be
on something else, A+.
So with that, and I haven't checked
it, but I'm hoping that this is clearly
in focus, but I thought about the
subject of focus in language learning.
When we learn a language, we kind of, and
I find that I sort of move from being very
focused on specific details to allowing,
you know, the language just to come in me,
into my brain without tremendous focus.
So, for example, I listen to my,
uh, you know, Lebanese TV program.
I don't really understand that much of it.
I kind of have understand it.
I'm starting, things are starting to
come into focus to the extent that I
can hear clearly where one word, uh,
ends and the next word begins, but
I don't necessarily know that word.
But it is sort of an increasing
focus that's developing, but it's
developing as I am allowing this
stuff to come in somewhat unfocused,
and then I will go in and study
that lesson sentence by sentence.
When you're studying sentence by sentence,
of course you're very much focused.
And the more focused I am, the more
I do the sort of, um, vocabulary
exercises, like the matching pairs or
trying to reconstitute the sentence,
which the, the sentence gets scrambled
I have to put it back together.
All of this is allowing me to focus in on
the language, focusing in on the language
of course, I am not acquiring as many new
words because when I'm going through the
whole text, it has a lot of blue words.
I'm running into these yellow words
that I've saved before I'm running
into them again, not necessarily
remembering, remembering them, but by
running into them again, I am sort of
somewhat strengthening my hold on them.
So, you know, I'm sort of pushed back
and forth or pulled back and forth.
So when I'm in the sort of unfocused
study mode, a lot of stuff is coming in.
It's a little bit fuzzy, uh,
gradually getting a little less fuzzy.
It has new words, it has a lot of yellow
words that I have still not learned,
but I'm covering a lot of material and
then I go and listen to it while I'm
doing the dishes, and I'm also covering
that material in a unfocused way.
And then it's possible to start to
feel frustrated because I continue
not understanding this stuff.
However, if I then focus in on a
particular issue, like a particular
sentence or maybe a particular
grammatical issue or, or, or any
particular sort of smaller sub, you
know, smaller detail in the language,
I'm always conscious of the fact, yeah
but I'm not acquiring new vocabulary.
So I'm pulled one way and then the
other, either I, I wanna get exposed
to the language, I wanna learn
new words, I want to increase...
I referred the other day to
sort of my reserve that our
memory can consist of a reserve.
Things that have come in, that they're in
reserve, but we can't yet retrieve them.
Uh, but if we focus on just making
sure we can retrieve those, then
we're gonna end up with a much
narrower, focused sort of subset.
So I think I often talk about the
need to vary what we do in language
learning, and I think to vary between
sort of focusing on a small part of the
language, trying to, you know, focus in
on a pattern, focus in on vocabulary,
focus in on a particular sentence.
You still have to mix in with
that, the sort of background.
So...
and the background is part of it.
You, even if you're very clear, like if
I have a clear picture right now on the
camera and I haven't had a look at it,
it's okay if the books in the background
are a little fuzzy and, and so I'm focused
in the, in the lens, but you also need the
background and, and we also need that sort
of building up of that larger, you know,
getting used to the language even though
it's still not really very much in focus.
So, uh, I just mentioned this because
I was thinking about focusing my camera
and then I thought about, you know, it,
it does help me even though it slows me
down to go sentence by sentence and pick
through it and work on the words and
reassemble the sentence, which kind of
shows me some aspects of grammar because
I have to try to remember or even think
through which word follows which word.
And while it's slowing me down I think
it is allowing me to focus in better
when I listen to the, the sort of
undifferentiated or the, the, the sort
of larger picture where there are many
new words or many words that I don't
know, but I, I get the feeling that
I'm better able to focus in on these
even because of the fact that I did
focus in on sentences for a while.
So I tend to go back and forth on
being very focused at times and
then allowing the language to come
at me in a sort of unfocused way.
So I don't know whether that's helpful,
but I think it's important that whatever
we're doing in the language, we want
to feel, at least, I want to feel
that what I'm doing is worthwhile.
It's a worthwhile use of my time.
And so for that reason, I have to remind
myself that, yeah, I keep on listening
to the, you know, the whole story.
Uh, the whole television interview,
and I keep on not understanding
it, but it doesn't matter because
that's building up my ability to see
it more clearly, to focus better.
And on the other hand, when I focus in
on a more limited bit of the language,
like a sentence or some aspect of
the language, it's slowing me down.
I'm not creating as many new LingQs.
I'm not reading as much.
Uh, but by focusing in on these sort
of, these samples of the language,
it is helping me focus again on the
broader, uh, sort of range of, of,
of language input that I'm getting.
So I don't know if that's helpful to you.
Uh, it's something that I
felt was meaningful to me.
It's a little bit, I should perhaps sit
down and think it through and, and do
some more research on it, but I just
thought I would share that with you.
So thank you for listening.
Bye for now.